[Musique]
rien foutu cette année ça sert à rien je
passe le bac il suffit juste que
celui-ci mette et tu l'auras pour
t'accompagner pas toujours drôle je vous
déteste c'est le blanc m'attaque
objectifs stratégiques admis la veille
du bac tu auras tout révisé moi car je
suis ravi de rencontrer votre papa pas
sa sueur
un petit rosé bordélique si vous pouvez
arrêter de m'appeler monde et des femmes
a pâti simple que ça cette cohabitation
olivier c'est marrant quand on vous voit
ensemble tous les deux vous faites un
couple parfait
d'un côté yolande et de l'autre le
bonnet du grand père un bac pro missiles
en kiosques ont fait leur faim la misère
qu'il a dit était en gros fainéant non
mais j'ai eu le faire sa fête la
gendarmette vous avez mélanger les
couleurs et maintenant tout mais
souhaite m'en sors tu peux me prêter
slip si vous voulez tifra suis là et que
les yeux qui pour ça c'était avant
ça se passe bien entre vous impliquer
tout à fait mai 68 s'affoler pas touche
à mon cactus ans tu veux la guerre
copenhague
l'amour
tu vas voir j'en dors portable
[Musique]
à l'époque ce mec vous êtes donc les
deux grands pères de camille je vais
vous expliquer mais je sais donner la
parole dont madame alors vous lever la
main